[Music]  fun group welcome to detention Spencer  Bethany fridge Martha you're all here  for a reason you know what it is you  should be thinking about who you are and  who you want to be fortunately you'll  have plenty of time to figure that out  while you're cleaning out the basement  that yo Spencer  this is Jumanji a game for those who  seek to find a way to leave their world  behind we're those avatar names so you  pick a character and then you're that  person in the game some groupie  I don't think it matters that much  should be playing  [Music]  they wear the rest of me my god  bridge damn fridge who are you it's me  Spencer who is she  think we got sucked into the game and  we've all become the avatars we chose so  that means I'm Bethany Bethany Bethany  [Applause]  I'm an overweight middle-aged man  welcome to Jumanji  Wow  I have to warn you I think I'm a very  strong puncher  don't cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna  be okay alright alright I can't  [Music]